voilà la garde républicaine est en train
d'arriver à quelques mètres maintenant
c'est une image toujours magnifique
l'été le début de l'automne seront sans
doute très dur très dur
il ya aujourd'hui un combat très intense
qui se passe à l'est de l'ukraine ils
sont le symbole du soutien de la france
à l'ukraine
les canons caesar sur les pavés des
champs elysées la russie utilise
l'énergie comme elle utilise d'ailleurs
l'alimentation comme une arme de guerre
vaut préparer un groupe totalement les
deux raisons je pense que nous devons
aujourd'hui nous préparer à un scénario
où il nous faut nous passer en totalité
du gaz russe
super
ces crises doivent toujours nous
apprendre comme le covin nous a appris
c'est très bon pour le climat et
l'indépendance justicier la même
bataille est-ce que sa sobriété une
partie de notre stratégie
en fait le maximum ici et on a fait
aussi des économies d'énergie en suivant
c'est à dire on fait de la rénovation et
vous verrez d'ailleurs aussi dans ce
parc peut-être dans quelques mois des
trous qui seront faits parce qu'on va se
chauffer aussi avec des systèmes de
géothermie
je joue bien
il ya des milliers de jeunes venant de
quartiers difficiles à qui on ne donnait
même pas de réponse alors cv qui ont été
embauchés par les vtc grâce à ça ils ont
trouvé leur première activité
professionnelle leur première paye ils
peuvent nourrir leur famille je vais
vous dire que je regrette jamais
qui débute par le carré des nations
étrangères opposé militaires issus de 9
pays membres de l'union européenne qui
sont hors du coup en ukraine moi je
serai toujours pour qu'on ouvre des
nouvelles possibilités dans notre
économie est pas qu on laisse des
chasses gardées
c'est marrant vos enchaînements de vos
questions plaisir c'est que on est les
premiers à dénoncer les surprofits mais
on est les premiers à vouloir les
laisser faire sous les yeux du président
pour la première fois le drones reaper
survolent la capitale
il est utilisé par les forces françaises
au sahel pour traquer les jihadistes
pour vous avez dû pas de hausses
d'impôts non on leur a dit je leur dis
ok je le redis à ce que tout va
continuer on va faire nos réformes et
ils ignorent complètement qui a une
crise économique qui a une crise
géopolitique qui a une crise monétaire
qui a une crise énergétique et il
annonce aux français qu'il va faire une
série de réformes comme si rien ne
s'était passé aux législatives qui vont
frapper les plus faibles alors que ceux
ci vont déjà se retrouver frappé par la
crise économique est ce que vous avez
peur ne passait à un quinquennat à avoir
vos projets retoqués non
qu'est ce qui vous permet de dire 50
cela que je crois à l'esprit de
responsabilité des formations politiques
qui sont intéressants
excellent pour une première fois jean
quelles sensations ça va ça rappelle le
pilote et les gros avions en fait c'est
un peu les mêmes les mêmes
d'anticipation même effet d'inertie est
ce qu'on est parti pour cinq ans
d'immobilisme et pas du tout d'abord
vous et même lundi matin vous n'avez pas
entendu depuis tout à l'heure si si
mais non mais attendez les interfaces en
fait c'est classique c'est fait pour
être compréhensible c'est ça le le
principe de base derrière c'est que ce
soit simple claire intuitive voilà je
parle plus par le jeu
je rate mon ces clasicos pensée a
évidemment un la nation et la trace
qu'on est dans l'histoire
et le voyez qu'on retienne quoi et le
pays avant tout n'écrit pas l'histoire
avant de la fleur ce palmipède pathos
paisiblement quand soudain
[Musique]
mais à europa park par un des membres du
personnel il ya deux semaines aux abords
d'une attraction ce canard catapulté
dans les airs par une fontaine a fait
s'envoler le nombre de vues plus de 40
millions et vous n'êtes plus jupiter
vous êtes devenu qui alors après j'ai
jamais revendiqué lé camp s'il jamais
revendiqué cette comparaison
mythologiques